la scène a comme un air de déjà vu et si
johnattan d'aval n'en a pas terminé avec
les juges sont d'aussi n'en a pas fini
avec les surprises
certaines pièces un monde ailleurs
émergé très opportunément ces derniers
jours au grand dam de ses avocats un
cheveu de sa mère découvert dans la
voiture qui a transporté le corps un
alibi taper sur son ordinateur et des
médicaments de type somnifères et
opiacés dans le sang de la victime
trois éléments tout sa charge tous
révélés par la famille d'alexia et qui
semble faire de johnatan un empoisonneur
est un assassin
c'est ce que sous-entendent les parties
civiles nous n'expliquons que peut-être
qu'on a essayé de provoquer des
somnolences pour provoquer un accident
peut-être que effectivement on a préparé
cette prise de médicaments pour
provoquer des amnésies volontairement et
donc sans aucun doute essayer d'arriver
vers une mort accidentelle par
l'emprisonnement et que in fine et on
est passé à une mort violente très
étonnant les parties civiles puisque ça
des parties civiles qui communiquent 1
instrumentalise qui vous instrumentalise
la presse ça c'est sûr que le timing est
important ils sont dans la stratégie
voilà donc c'est assez curieux tout ça
curieux mais après tout c'est leur choix
cinq heures durant johnattan d'aval que
ses avocats disent très affectés par
tout ça va tout de même maintenir sa
version des faits celle du complot
familial avec son beau frère grégory gay
dans le rôle du meurtrier
une version qu'il va devoir défendre de
nouveau dans huit jours face à chacun
des membres de sa belle-famille
un par un les yeux dans les yeux la
confrontation reste un moment
extrêmement tendue extrêmement
émotionnelles tribune en tension
émotionnelle parce que je vous rappelle
que quand même on a été tellement
proches les uns des autres
il s'agit quasiment de de gens de sa
famille avec qui va être confronté donc
peu importe ce qui s'est passé le moment
où ils seront mis en présence va être à
mon sens un moment clé de ce dossier
et parce que johnattan d'aval refuse
logiquement de se prêter à une
reconstitution des faits qu'il nie avoir
commis
cette confrontation pourrait bien être
le dernier acte de l'instruction sous
réserve d'un de ces rebondissements dont
la sphère a le secret